what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and a couple of days ago
we got the official teaser trailer for
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania and
it looks amazing we watched Scotland AKA
Ant-Man his daughter Cassie Ling hope
Van Dyne Janet Van Dyne and Hank Pym get
sucked into the quantum realm where we
saw a lot of new characters including
Bill Murray and Kang the Conqueror or
should I say Kings you see I think
Marvel is doing what they typically do
with teaser trailers and trailers they
are kind of trying to deceive us but I
mean that in a very good way they're
trying not to give it all away but I
believe that we have discovered what the
actual plot for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania is and it may not be exactly
what you think it is based off of some
things that Marvel Studios president
Kevin feige has told us and based off of
some small details in the trailer I
believe that we're going to see many
different variants in this movie
different variants of Ant-Man but also
different variants of King you see Kevin
feige has already confirmed that there
are going to be multiple different
variants of Kang in The multiversal Saga
which makes sense it is the Multiverse
Saga and it's all leading up to the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars where of course
we'll see just a ton of different
variants of a ton of different
characters but let's specifically just
look at Ant-Man and the WASP since we
just got the trailer Monday and let's
specifically look at a few scenes and
what Kang specifically tells Ant-Man or
should I say a version of King tells
Ant-Man for the most part the vast
majority of this trailer is spent inside
of the quantum realm with the exception
of perhaps the first 20 seconds there's
a lot that goes on but there are a few
very important details to focus on one
of the first things to notice is what a
variant of King is telling Ant-Man as we
see Kang or at least from the head down
we don't actually see his head but as we
see King for the very first time he is
putting some type of power source into
some type of a device now this is
obviously show shown because the trailer
wants you to see this it wants to be
emphasized so it's going to be a big
part of the movie and this is hinted at
in the trailer however something that
wasn't shown in this trailer that was
shown in the footage at sdcc and d23
earlier this year was footage of Kang
the Conqueror basically telling Ant-Man
that he wants Ant-Man to steal something
for him that is sort of relayed in this
trailer king says this place isn't what
you think he says I can get you home and
give you more time if you help me and
the trailer ends with Kang asking
Ant-Man so what's it gonna be meaning
are you going to help me and I believe
that he is I believe this King wants
this power source from a different King
the Conqueror we see a few different
shots of Kang in this trailer but if you
notice if you look very carefully the
outfits they're wearing are slightly
different and that is because I believe
we are seeing two different Kings here
one king who isn't so much in power and
one King who is and the other king needs
the help of Ant-Man to steal something
from the king in power so he can get in
power so it almost becomes sort of like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
except we know that Kang is still going
to be the enemy of Ant-Man even though
he needs the help of him but the
question is why does Kang one variant of
King need the help of Ant-Man well you
have to remember what he who remains who
of course is a variant of Kang he even
said in Loki they've called me a
conqueror before you have to remember
what he said about all of his variants
fighting each other the multiversal War
was between Kings it wasn't just between
a bunch of different universes a bunch
of different people it was literally
between a bunch of different variants of
Kang the Conqueror he who remains then
shut everything down and created One
Soul sacred timeline to keep other
variants of Kane from emerging however
like he who remains told Loki and Sylvie
if they killed him the Multiverse would
essentially break open again and his
variance would come which is exactly
what is happening now so within our MCA
Ray right now within our Multiverse a
huge multiversal War has already broken
out between the Kings and we are
witnessing it right now in Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania and now Ant-Man has
been brought into this multiversal war
whether he likes it or not but again why
does Kang need ant-man's help well
because he can shrink down to a size
that nobody else can see even inside of
the quantum realm as we can see in one
specific shot we see giant man meaning
that even though Ant-Man is able to
shrink down and get into the quantum
realm he can still shrink even more and
he can still grow bigger inside of the
quantum realm this is the very specific
skill set that this version of King
needs so Ant-Man can go sneak in grab
the power source and sneak out and
there's a very specific reason that this
King the Conqueror needs that power
source we'll talk about that in just a
second but first big thank you to
wondery and the Lord of the Rings the
rings of power official podcast for
sponsoring this video now I know a lot
of you like me have watched The Lord of
the Rings the rings of power on Amazon
it's amazing using I loved it and since
you're on my Channel right now you
probably love to dive even deeper than
just watching the show and now you can
go deeper into the canals of numenor the
minds of Kaza doom and more with the
official the Lord of the Rings rings of
power podcast host Felicia Day who many
people probably know and several special
guests provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunner DJ Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs you won't want
to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app right now to listen to The
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast now in Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania we actually saw Kang's time
chair Kang's time chair is essentially
how he travels through time and without
it he's kind of stuck inside of the
quantum realm which is why he needs
ant-man's help the other king the
Conqueror who has clearly conquered the
quantum realm or the vast majority of it
since we see pretty much an entire Army
a very very huge Army and essentially
the city chronopolis which is the
headquarters of King in the comics which
is located in limbo which essentially
exists outside of space and time aka the
quantum realm this Kang right here is
pretty much the dominant King and I'm
assuming that he pretty much controls
all of the power sources needed to power
time travel devices you see when King
the Conqueror tells Ant-Man this place
is not what you think it is kind of what
we think the quantum realm is the home
of chronopolis and is King the
conqueror's headquarters for the same
reasons that it is in limbo in the
comics it exists outside of space and
time but is the hub for Kang to jump to
different places in time in different
universes the quantum realm makes that
possible we saw this in Avengers end
game The Avengers all went inside of the
quantum realm at the same time however
they went through different portals and
went to different parts in time this is
essentially what king the Conqueror does
however he can also go to other
universes because he has mastered this
The Avengers managed to put it out but
Kang is the master of time travel he can
control it way better than anybody could
ever imagine and this is what makes Kang
so dangerous but make no mistake we are
going to be seeing a battle of the Kings
and I believe Ant-Man and a bunch of
different variants of Ant-Man are going
to help a specific variant of king take
down kind of the big bad King if you
will there is a very specific scene in
the trailer where we see Ant-Man running
with a lot of other Ant-Man if you look
at the very bottom of the scene you can
see a bunch of different variants of
Ant-Man and we can see a very large
variant of Ant-Man gets shredded to
string cheese like we saw Mr Fantastic
get shredded in Multiverse of Madness so
we're clearly going to be seeing a lot
of different variants of Ant-Man in this
movie but I I wouldn't be shocked if we
saw some variants of some other
characters as well we know from the
footage that was shown at d23 and sdcc
that King the Conqueror drops the line
to Ant-Man you're an Avenger have I
killed you before meaning that Kang has
ran into other Avengers before perhaps
he has taken some prisoner and perhaps
some are being held inside of
chronopolis heck maybe even some
variants that are evil are working with
King and are part of his army but that
line have I killed you before actually
ties in with a line that one of the
other kings has said in this trailer
where he says I can get you out and give
you more time I believe this is because
obviously King the Conqueror can see the
future multiple different Futures and
has seen that future where a variant of
Kang has killed Ant-Man and I think this
is what he is referring to when he is
saying and I can give you more time
meaning you don't have to die at the
hands of this other king the Conqueror I
myself can save you if you help me
basically get in charge and from what
we've heard this came to conqueror of
course he's still evil basically takes
Scott's daughter Cassie hostage so it's
pretty much not really a choice he
basically says Hey Ant-Man you're gonna
help me or I'm gonna hurt your daughter
so essentially Ant-Man has been brought
into this multiversal war of Kings I
believe he's going to end up helping
this variant of Kang Dethrone the other
variant but in turn create the big bad
of the MCU the main Kang that we'll see
throughout the rest of the multiversal
Saga and perhaps even the main Kang of
the Kang Dynasty based off of what we've
seen in this trailer this seems to make
sense but hey let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments down
below and of course let me know what you
thought about that awesome trailer don't
forget to subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf
foreign